hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wild ich habe heute ganz leckeres
ganz einfaches sehr schnelles und total
schönes gericht für euch ich mache heute
nämlich eine zitronen früchte tat gesagt
vielleicht der ein oder andere wieder oh
gott nicht schon wieder die wm
ich weiß einiges im wm-fieber andere
wollen lieber gar nicht erst wissen weil
sie keine fußballfans sind aber diese
tat habe ich zwei jetzt so bisschen
schwarz rot gold mäßig dekoriert aber
ihr könnt natürlich auch ganz andere
früchte nehmen und ein ganz anderes
muster drauf zaubern
ich habe mich einfach dazu entschlossen
diese tag zu machen weil ich finde dass
man bei diesem wetter nicht so viel in
der küche stehen will selbst ich nicht
und ich bin lieber draußen in der natur
und deswegen sollte es ein schnelles
rezept seien im verein faches und das
ist wirklich für jedermann
ich habe außerdem darauf geachtet dass
ich jetzt einfach so nötig gemacht habe
und ich hab den mürbeteig zwei mal
gemacht und zwar einmal mit normalem
mehl und einmal mit glutenfreien mail
und da zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal
meine erfahrungen und wie es mir dabei
ergangen ist als ich die torte
zubereitet habe oder die tat besser
gesagt und deswegen nehme ich euch
direkt mit in die küche und wette mit
vorbereiten
für den mürbeteig brauchen wir 125 gramm
butter 250 gramm mehl 80 gramm
puderzucker eine prise salz und ein ei
und hier zeige ich euch jetzt noch das
glutenfreie mail und zwar fühlt sich das
an
so wie speisestärke also richtig fein
sehr pulverig und mit dem werde ich
später noch den zweiten mit vorbereiten
jetzt gebe ich einfach alle zutaten in
eine schüssel und beste dann ganz
schnell mit meinen händen
zu einem teig verkneten das könnte
natürlich auch mit einer küchenmaschine
mit den knethaken machen aber da täglich
innerhalb und zwei minuten geknetet und
sollte einfach ganz schnell verarbeitet
werden
danach wirklich ihnen etwas
frischhaltefolie ein und geht ihnen dann
für mindestens eine stunde in den
kühlschrank den guten freien tag werde
ich für etwa zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank geben
hier könnt ihr einfach mal den
unterschied sehen zwischen dem normalen
tag mit normalem mehl und stinkt lud
ihren freien tag meine tages werde ich
in der tat vom bakken
ich hab dir auch mit einer obstkuchen
formal versucht und ich bin mit diesen
zwei formen nicht ganz zufrieden weil
man einfach den boden nicht herausheben
kann ich habe jetzt bereits für mich tat
formen mit herausnehmbaren boden
bestellt die haben auch einen schönen
welligen rand und jetzt müsst ihr den
teig etwas größer als eure form aus
wollen damit ihr einfach nur einen
schönen land bekommt das ganze mache ich
auf meinen silikon matten weil die
einfach nicht kleben und ich einfach
sehr wenig mehl benutzen kann
die tat formen werde ich jetzt noch mit
butter bepinseln und dann mit etwas mehl
bestäuben damit dass später einfach
nichts dran geht
und kam dann mit meinem silikon aus rolf
starb ganz einfach den teig ausrollen
der stilikone auswahl starb einfach den
vorteil dass man nicht so viel mehr
benutzen muss war einfach nichts daran
haften bleibt und er hat keine griffe
das heißt ihr müsst ihr mit dem händen
dann in der mitte ansetzen und hab dann
so immer den gleichen druck und könnte
so euren teig schneller und viel besser
ausrollen
ich habe jetzt bei dem glutenfreien teig
den fehler gemacht dass ich den teig zu
dünn ausgerollt habe und dann praktisch
zu viel zeit übrig blieb das macht ihr
bitte nicht sondern holt ihn etwas
dicker aus so dass der teig ganz genau
für diese form reicht ich habe nur 24 cm
form benutzt denn mein tag ist
anschließend gebrochen aber das zeige
ich euch später dann einfach bitte es
silikon mathe habe ich einfach den
vorteil dass ich den teig mit das
silikon matte direkt auf meine form
legen kann und kann dann so den teig in
die form gleiten lassen ohne dass sich
zu sehr drücken muss und aufpassen muss
dass mit der zeit nicht reißt und dann
kann ich einfach die ränder wegnehmen
und wie gesagt martin zwei mir zu groß
deswegen solltet ihr den teig nur etwa
26 27 cm groß ausrollen und dann dürfte
das ganze ganz perfekt passen
der teig wird jetzt noch mit einer gabel
eingestochen und muss dann noch mal für
etwa 15 minuten in den gefrierschrank
und in dieser zeit hat sich schon mal
den backofen auf 190 grad ober und
unterhitze vor und werde anschließend
den teig darin für etwa 25 minuten
backen
man kann sie bereits erkennen dass der
teig etwas zu dünn war und deswegen ist
mir leider auch gebrochen und ich konnte
ihn nicht weiter verwenden
deswegen dürfte den putin freitag nicht
zu dünn ausrollen also das war jetzt
auch mein fehler wie so etwas passiert
ist das ganze hab ich dann noch mal
gemacht in der gleichen form habe ihn
nicht so dünn ausgerollt und dann hatte
ich einen wunderschönen tag
anschließend könnt ihr das ganze aus der
form stürzen und dann wieder umdrehen
und zum abkühlen am besten auf und
kuchengitter legen damit einfach von
oben und unten die luft entweichen kann
und der teig richtig schön knusprig
bleibt nun werde ich anschließend das
leveln card vorbereiten und dieses habe
ich jetzt heute in einem topf gemacht
damit ihr einfach mal sehen könnt wie
man das level könnt im topf zubereitet
ich hätte es jetzt privat in meinem
thermomix zubereitet weil ich da einfach
nicht dabei stehen muss und das ganze
rühren muss dafür braucht ihr zwei eier
100 milliliter zitronensaft 150 gramm
zucker 50 gramm butter und zwei
esslöffel zitronenschale
die zutaten kommen alle gemeinsam in den
topf und werden einfach mal schön glatt
gerührt und bei mittlerer hitze werde
ich dann das lernen hört schön rühren
und unter ständigem rühren leicht
köcheln lassen ist die masse richtig
günstig ist also das dauerte familie zu
etwa 58 minuten und dann müsst ihr
wirklich ständig rühren damit einfach
das ei nicht stockt sondern das ganze
richtig schön gebunden wird
danach könnt ihr dann das lenkrad direkt
in die abgekühlte tat form geben
wer möchte kann es vorher noch durch
einen sieg streichen damit auch wirklich
keine klümpchen darin enthalten sind mir
warte slimane gehört ein bisschen zu süß
das heißt ich würde das nächste mal nur
100 gramm zucker nehmen und eventuell
etwas weniger lemon curt einfüllen für
die deko habe ich jetzt eine mango
genommen und bei der mango solltet ihr
beim kauf darauf achten dass sie etwas
weich ist und nicht mehr ganz grün
denn das zeigt auch dass sie eben es
reif ist und schön süß ist die mango
will jetzt halbiert mit einem scharfen
messer und zwischendrin ist ein ganz
großer flacher kern dem müsst ihr mit
einem messer umfahren
das merkte dann einfach am widerstand
und auf der anderen seite eben genauso
so dass der kern in der mitte einfach ab
stück blei
dieses stück mit dem kern habe ich jetzt
zur seite gelegt da werde ich aber
danach noch das fruchtfleisch entfernen
so dass einfach nur noch der kern übrig
bleibt und er kann dann weggeschmissen
werden die zwei mango helfen werde ich
jetzt nicht stehlen sondern werde sie
einritzen und da passt ihr auch dass er
sie nicht ganz durchschneidet denn dann
könnt ihr später die gewürfelten mango
stückchen ganz einfach entfernen
zuerst werden jetzt längsstreifen
eingeschnitten die waren bei mir jetzt
etwa ein zentimeter breit
dann die querstreifen dazu die waren
auch ein zentimeter breit und dann könnt
ihr die mango etwas nach außen formen
und die abstehenden fruchtstücke könnt
ihr dann ganz einfach mit dem messer
abnehmen ohne dass ihr jetzt einen
großen aufwand habt und so könnt ihr
richtig schöne kleine manko stückchen
abschneiden
ich wollte jetzt meine tat eben in
dieser deutschlandflagge machen deswegen
habe ich die mango als gelbe frucht
genommen dann die himbeeren als rote
frucht und brombeeren als schwarze frau
ihr könnt natürlich jeder andere
hochnehmen und ich werde auch meine
zweite tat ohne diese vielen früchte
belegen sondern einfach mit einfach in
bendigo ringen
ich habe dann damit begonnen die tat von
außen nach innen zu dekorieren und zwar
außen eine reihe rhomberg
dann kam ein mann dazwischen und fand
die idee besser zwei reihen von bands
machen zwei reihen himbeeren und dann
den rest mit dem mango stückchen ihr
könnt es natürlich zu dekorieren wie er
das möchte
und dann ist die tat auch schon fertig
ich bin jetzt wieder daheim und zeigt
euch jetzt den kuchen einfach mal
angeschnitten muss ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein in sehr scharfes messer
benutzen weil der teig knusprig ist aber
das wollen wir auch so das ist jetzt der
nicht glutenfreie sieht wunderschön aus
oder mit den verschiedenen beeren drauf
mit den früchten hier unten der keks
boden dann die leckere cremige zitronen
schicht und dann einfach fruchtige wären
und jetzt zeige ich euch noch den
glutenfreien kuchen natürlich ist es
jetzt so ich hab das jetzt alles in
einem ofen gebacken habe mit dem
gleichen werkzeug gearbeitet also das
würde ich jetzt keinen geben der
wirklich eine glutenunverträglichkeit
hat weil da muss man wirklich sehr
penibel sein und auch getrennt das
werkzeug benutzen das darf alles nicht
in berührung kommen nicht mal der staub
von weizenmehl oder so darf damit rein
kommen aber ich wollte einfach mal
wissen wie das ist mit diesem mehr zu
arbeiten und ich muss sagen das war
wirklich so toll ich finde es mir
richtig klasse da muss ich glaube ich
jetzt bisschen mehr aufpassen beim
schneiden weil er etwas vater auch ist
hier aber der schwedische talfahrt als
auch freuen als ich diese keks größte
gegessen habe heute sind total lecker
hab mir gesagt zur zeit richtig lecker
mit dem level körper und ihr habt ja
wahrscheinlich mein video gesehen über
glutenfreies backen und falls ihr uns
nicht gesehen habt könnt ihr durch gerne
hier noch einmal anklicken oder in der
infobox
und zwar hatte ich eine e mail von der
leben nele bekommen die mir einfach so
über ihre unverträglichkeit geschrieben
hat und das hat mich ja sehr betroffen
gemacht und das war nicht die einzige e
mail dem ich dich empfangen habt sondern
das waren ja mehrere und deswegen hatte
ich ja das video gemacht und dabei hat
mich eben die firma drk unterstützt mit
dem mit informationen und ich ganz viel
gelesen auch und auch die anne von
glutenfreien shop in waghäusel hat mich
sehr unterstützt und hat mir alle fragen
beantwortet und ich hab mir da diese
produkte von cher eben mehr zugelegt und
hab mir dann damit es eben ausprobiert
und jetzt hat mir die firma doktor
scheer nachdem ich dieses video gemacht
habe eine ganze produktpalette geschickt
damit ich sie lieben nämlich schicken
kann
weil die habs auch ganz arg berührt was
eben in dieser e-mail drin stand
deswegen lieber nele sind diese ganzen
produkte tätig jetzt alle für dich und
ich hoffe dass ganz viel spaß damit
ich zeige es hier auch mal und auch mein
lieferant weit da ganz akte hilfreich
und zwar die firma steht hat sich jetzt
dazu bereit erklärt die rheinbach
starterset von mir zu schenken und zwar
kannst du das hier sehen und zwar ist es
mein bugs etwas du aus meinen videos
wahrscheinlich schon kennst da fehlt
jetzt noch die eckige back unterlage die
ich natürlich auch dabei und auch eine
zweite dauer back folie aber bei mir
steckt alles gerade in kartons deswegen
konnte ich das nicht zeigen und das
bekommst du alles zur verfügung gestellt
und natürlich auch eine stütze von mir
keine handgemachte aber eine schied aus
meinem shop und das ist alles für dich
und auch für die anderen die vielleicht
an nikotin und verträglichkeit leiden
habe ich mir jetzt gedacht weil ich
diese produkte jetzt auch in doppelter
ausführung bekommen habe da sich das
einfach so eine kleine verlosung macht
das heißt wenn ihr gerne die produkte
von cher
möchte schreibt einfach einen kommentar
unten in die kommentare
und ich stelle dann einfach das päckchen
zusammen und ihr müsst mir dann eben
noch eine e mail schreiben mit eurem mit
eurer adresse
aber das macht ihr bitte erst nachdem
ich euch über den kommentar dann
kontaktiert habe und stand bekommt ihr
einfach die sachen weil ich brauche ja
im prinzip gar nicht ich bin zwar ganz
lecker aber ich denke dass ihr sie eben
viel er gebrauchen könnt und bevor ich
jetzt das video beenden möchte ich mich
ganz kurz bei der gruppe bei der
facebook gruppe zum austausch bedanken
weil ich dort auch mein video gepostet
habe und da ganz ganz viel feedback
bekommen habe
vielen dank an der stelle und ich habe
gesagt ich möchte mich mal wieder wenn
ich hilfe brauche oder einen ratschlag
und ich glaube dieses video habt ihr es
bestimmt auch schon gesehen weil ich sag
gepostet habe deswegen ganz ganz
herzlichen dank an euch alle
und falls ihr die gruppe noch nicht
kämpfen auch betroffen seid dann geht da
einfach mal rein
da ist wirklich ein reger austausch und
da könnt ihr fragen stellen bekommt alle
antworten und das finde ich ganz toll
das rezept gibt es natürlich auf meinem
blog auf www police torten welt.de
ich nehme zitate verteilt noch ein
bisschen an meiner nachbarschaft ich bin
umgezogen da muss man ein bisschen auch
die nachbarn zu zeigen
ich gehe zwei nachbarn
bis zum nächsten mal ciao
die einfach von betroffenen man total
verändert shop kannst du bleibe ich
kannte weil du mich ablenkt noch mal